الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور ادمنت
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه على اي مدى
اولا تتفق مع المبررات التي قدمها التقرير
حول عدم
مراجعه اداره الرئيس الامريكي للعلاقه مع
السعوديه وهو الامر الذي كان قد تحدث به
هو والكثير من اعضاء الكونجرس في فتره
سابق
فعلا اعتقد اولا انه كان هناك
فتور او البعض طبعا يصفها بانها كانت ازمه
في العلاقات او عدم ثقه
قامت بين الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
وخاصه بعد التصريحات التي ادلى بها الرئيس
بايدن السعوديه ستكون دوله منبوده عندما
كان مرشحا للرئاسه
وطبعا برزت ايضا كما ذكرتم هذه التباينات
في المواقف والانزعاج الامريكي بعد قرار
اوبك بلس في السنه الماضيه بتخفيض الانتاج
وحتى في الاونه الاخيره ولكن في نفس الوقت
الذي
جرد عليك اعتقد انه كان هناك فعلا نوع من
اعاده التقييم
لسوى المراجعه للسياسه الامريكيه وكان
هناك تيار كان هناك اكثر من تيار طبعا
هناك تيار في الكونجرس يطالب بتبني مواقف
متش محاسبه السعوديه بمعاقبتها بعدم ارسال
الاسلحه وغير ذلك هناك دعم له من بعض
المسؤولين ولكن هناك طيار اخر يعتقد بان
الاداره الامريكيه
ضيعت الطابه الى حد ما او اسقطتها من
اسقطت الكره الدبلوماسيه في من يدها وانها
او انها اتبعت دبلوماسيه فاشله ولم تاخذ
مصالح ودول حلفائها في المنطقه والشركائها
بعين الاعتبار او لم تمنحهم الاهتمام
الكافي وانه يجب اعاده النظر في ذلك ولذلك
راينا انه على الرغم من عدم ارتياح واشنطن
لتخفيض الاسعار كان هناك نوع من القرار
الذي اتخذ بعدم تصعيد
مع السعوديه لان العلاقات بين البلدين هي
علاقات وثيقه لا تزال هناك مصالح مشتركه
كثيره بين السعوديه والولايات المتحده
ويجب ان تاخذها الولايات المتحده دعاني
وكان هناك فعلا عده مؤشرات ايجابيه في
الاونه الاخيره في العلاقات بين الجانبين
مثلا وافق موافقه الكونجرس بعد ان رفع احد
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذي كان يرفض تعيين
السفير او يعلق دكتور برايك بسبب قضايا
تتعلق
والموافقه على ارسال السفير الى السعوديه
ايضا الصفقه صفقه شراء طائرات
من
الولايات المتحده من شركه بوينج قبل
السعوديه
والزياره التي تفضلتم واشرتم في اليها
ايضا زياره
الرئيس او مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزي
وهو يعتبر ايضا كان كما تعلم دبلوماسيا
بارسا كان رقم اثنين في وزاره الخارجيه
قبل تعيينه في منصب مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه وهذه اظهرت بان
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه لا تزال على
الرغم من بعض التباينات لا تزال لديهم
علاقات قويه وتاريخيه وثيقه ان كانت
اقتصاديه ان كانت تعليميه عسكريه امنيه
وغير ذلك ولذلك فان كان نوع من التفاهم
والتقبل ولكن حتى ولو لم يكن مرحبا به
للمتغيرات فيما يتعلق مثلا بالصفقه التي
التفاهم الذي تم بين السعوديه وايران
ببصاصه الصين وتعزيز العلاقه ايضا مع
روسيا وان ذلك جاء كما يعتقد البعض هنا
طبعا هناك تفسيران مختلفان بعض يعتقد بان
السعوديه لا تزال ترغب في الحفاظ على
علاقه وثيقه مع الولايات المتحده وتتخذ
خطوات لذلك ولكنها قلقه من بعض المواقف
الامريكيه في الماضي وسبب الاخر يرى بان
السعوديه ايضا تتبنى توجه جديدا سياسه
خارجيه جديده تاخذ بعين الاعتبار
المتغيرات الدوليه والتعدديه القطبيه
وتنظر الى هذه المساله من وجهه نظر
مصلحتها ومصلحه شعبها وبالتالي فان هذه هي
ايضا من بين العوامل ولكن كما قلت هناك
تفسيرات مختلفه لهذه التطورات جيد يعني
الدكتور باختصار هل نتحدث عن تحسن تدريجي
في العلاقه بين الرياض واشنطن واقعيه
امريكيه في النظر الى مكانه وقوه القرار
اليوم في الرياض ام انه ضعف اليوم ضعف
امريكي واضح الولايات المتحده لم تعد
قادره على اتخاذ القرار في الخليج العربي
براي اعتقد انها ربما قد تكون مزيج من كل
هذه العوامل بدون شك ان هناك تحسن
ونقل قبل حوالي اسبوع ونصف او اسبوعين
تقريبا
تصريح نسب لمسؤول بارز امريكي ولكن يذكر
يذكر اسمه وهو ان العلاقه الان هي في وضع
افضل مما كانت عليه بكثير من ما كانت عليه
في بين السعوديه
والولايات المتحده وان الولايات المتحده
تتفهم بعض المواقف التي
تتفهمها او تبنتها العربيه السعوديه ولذلك
اعتقد ان هناك فعلا تحسن في العلاقات ولكن
ايضا الولايات المتحده منشغله لديها
الكثير على طاولته على المائده وفي الامور
يجب عليها ان تتعامل معها وتعالجها وواجهت
عده صدمات ربما في الاونه الاخيره وهذه
ايضا لها علاقه فهي تريد الحفاظ على
علاقاتها وعلى دورها وهي لا تزال تقول
لانها هناك عده تطورات ايضا اخرى دكتور
علاقات وثيقه مع شركائها التقليدي على
سبيل المثال اتفاق السعودي الايراني
الكثير من الامريكيين من خلال متابعتنا
ربما لوسائل الاعلام للتعليقات ايضا بعض
المسؤولين
يعتبرون ذلك انتصار للصين هزيمه لسياسه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انضمام
السعوديه ايضا في صفه شريك حوار لمنظمه
شنغهاي
زياره ويليام مثلا مدير وكاله المخابرات
الامريكيه وما قيل بانه جاء يعني يعبر في
زيارته عن انزعاج امريكي من التقارب بين
الرياض والطيران من الوساطه الصينيه
وغيرها كل ذلك الى اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر في
في العلاقه اليوم بين واشنطن وبين الرياض
اعتقد ان اولا بدون شك واشنطن كان انزعجت
كانت منزعجه من
الدور الذي لعبته الصين في البساطه
الايرانيه السعوديه ورات بذلك انه دور
جديد تلعبه الصين على الساحه الاقليميه
وهذا طبعا بالتاكيد كما هو نتوقعه ومزعج
لواشنطن ايضا هناك عدد من مثلا رغبه
السعوديه في الانضمام لمنظمات شان عائله
التعاون هذه ايضا مزعجه ولكن في نفس الوقت
ايضا بدات هناك الواقعيين داخل الاداره
الامريكيه يقول بانه على الرغم من ان كل
هذه
القرارات التي اخذتها السعوديه فان
السعوديه لا تزال هي دوله لها علاقات
وثيقه مع الولايات المتحده هذه العلاقات
قديمه جدا وهي لن تهتز او لن تتاثر كثيرا
بسبب هذه الرساله الامريكيه النوويه هل
ياتي في هذا السياق في هذا الاطار في هذا
التوقيت له فعلا وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا اعتقد
ان الولايات المتحده ايضا بارسالها هذه
الغواصه النوويه
وعاده ارسال الغواصه مثلا او معظم الاوقات
يتم بسريه عاليه هذه المره نشرت صوره وقد
كان هناك حديث عنها وتم ربطها في وسائل
وسائل الاعلام الامريكي بانها اشاره على
ان الولايات المتحده لا تزال باقيه في
المنطقه وهي رساله طمانه لترسلها الى
اصدقائها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولذلك
اعتقد ان هذه قد تكون ايضا من بين الرسائل
التي ترغب واشنطن في ارسالها ولكن ايضا
البعض يقول بان وهذه الجانب الواقعيه التي
بدات يعترف بها بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين
قبل عده سنوات كانت الولايات المتحده
المشتري الاول للنفط من السعوديه الان
اكبر ثاني الصيني المشتريات السعوديه هي
ثاني اكبر مشتريات نفطيه في العالم وتاتي
من السعوديه وهذه ايضا عامل اخر مهم
بالنسبه ان السعوديه ايضا تاخذ مصالحه هذه
الاعتبار لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات